seven patrons of a sushi restaurant in
Florida were unknowingly drugged with
methamphetamine an unemployed man was
spotted dressed as a chef in the sushi
bar kitchen that served this food that
he did not work at I'm saying these
events are connected sometimes you wake
up and you're like I want to do some
crime no one has ever thought of
dressing up like a chef walking into a
sushi restaurant and handing out meth I
eat sushi all the time if someone just
randomly made a sushi I would know I
would be like this isn't real does it
have meth in it because that's what I
would think have you ever been to a
sushi restaurant it's a small kitchen so
I don't know how long he was back there
if you eat sushi and you bite into
something crunchy and meth-like don't
eat any more Sushi he somehow got it
into the food they tested the soy sauce
afterwards and it tested positive for me
this guy really was a sushi chef who was
recently fired at another nearby sushi
restaurant so he wants revenge on sushi
restaurants in general he had gone back
to the same one and then they said okay
he's getting revenge but going to a
different sushi restaurant is God level